The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I know I'm
not Dr. Sadoway.
I'm one of Dr. Sadoway's
younger colleagues so--
but class is beginning,
so let's get started.
Dr. Sadoway, of course, would
like you to know that he would
very much love to be with you
here today and he would
probably like that very much
more than what he's doing now,
which is sitting in a secured
area secured by the Secret
Service about to meet
the President.
So you can ask him all about
it when he comes back.
Associated with that, I have
one request for you.
Today, when you're leaving,
some of you may be used to
leaving that way.
Don't leave that way.
Leave any other way.
This way's fine.
In the back is fine.
Just don't leave that way.
OK.
So last time, we talked
about x-rays
defraction and Bragg's Law.
And x-ray defraction and Bragg's
Law has a lot to do
with perfect crystals.
So perfection, right?
We've been dealing with perfect
crystal so far and
today, we're going to be dealing
with imperfections.
So defects.
And in the field of material
science, the field that I work
in along with Dr. Sadoway.
there's a saying due to one of
the most famous material
scientists that says that
crystals are like people.
It's the defects that make
them interesting.
So now you've heard that saying
and you can roll your
eyes from now on every time
you hear it because it's
repeated it very often.
So let's see.
What do we mean by defects?
Well, there's two types of
defects, broadly speaking,
that we're going to be talking
about, and we can classify
those into two categories.
One of them is chemical.
So far, we've been dealing with
chemically perfect materials.
So ones that are made up of one
element or ones that are
made up in stoichiometric
quantities of two elements,
but you can also have chemical
imperfections.
You can have impurities.
You can have alloying elements
and we're also going to be
talking about atomic
arrangement.
And in the case of atomic
arrangement, we're dealing
with structure, right?
Here we're dealing
with chemistry.
with structure.
You know about crystal structure
so you know what
perfect crystals look like,
but real materials are not
perfect, neither in the chemical
sense nor in the
structural sense.
So perfect crystals don't really
exist. You have always
some forms of imperfections and
we'll go over those today.
So in the case of chemical
imperfections, we have,
broadly speaking, two types.
Good ones--
Dr. Sadoway labels them with
a smiley face so I
will do that, too.
And bad ones are a sad face.
So both are defects and whether
they're good or bad
depends on their utility.
Are they useful or are
they detrimental?
If they are detrimental, we
call them impurities.
And if they are good, we
call them other things.
For example, dopants.
We studied dopants, right?
Dopants are a type of impurity,
they're a kind of
imperfection, but
they're good.
We use dopants.
We use them in semiconductors.
Also, alloying elements,
you can put in
the elements yourself.
Those are examples of good
chemical imperfections.
When it comes to atomic
arrangements, we're going to
spend a little bit of time
talking about that in more
detail in just a minute.
But broadly speaking, they are
situations where you don't
have perfect crystal in order.
You have disruptions and that
perfect crystal in order--
either in the form of missing
atoms or extra atoms or
differently oriented
unit cells of the
crystal and so forth.
So we'll talk about
that a little bit
more in just a minute.
So one thing that I forgot to
mention maybe is that we have
a test coming up--
That is, I'm sorry.
Celebration of learning, second
celebration of learning.
And those are your
room assignments.
You don't have to necessarily
write them down now, but
you'll see them again.
So I just wanted you
to see them.
A through Ha in 10-250,
He through Sm, 26-100,
So through Z, 4-270.
OK, so let's go into the
taxonomy of defects.
So I mentioned that there are a
number of different kinds of
defects, and we can do better
than to say simply, defects
exist. We can actually start
to classify them.
So there are, broadly speaking,
four types of
defects, which we classify
based on dimensionality.
So there's 0-dimensional defects
and 0-dimensional
defects are point defects or
point defect clusters.
It's just like in math.
A point has 0 dimension,
right?
1-dimensional defects or line
defects, things that thread
through a material like a
shoestring or something, and
we'll have an example of that
in the form of dislocations.
Then we have 2-dimensional
defects.
Those are interfacial defects.
So if you have interfaces
between two different kinds of
materials or if you have two
crystals that are misoriented
with respect to each other,
those are examples of
interfacial defects.
And we also have
bulk defects--
3-dimensional defects
like inclusions.
We'll go over some of those.
So let's start out with
point defects.
Point defects are those
0-dimensional defects.
They're points, just
like in math.
And there are a number of
different point defects that
we can look at.
We have our substitutional
impurities, interstitial
impurities.
The general overall recurring
theme in these point defects,
regardless what type they are,
is that they are localized
disruptions.
So a lattice, a crystalline
lattice, is a regular
arrangement of atoms, and a
point defect is a very local
disruption in that regular
crystalline arrangement.
And those disruptions can
occur on lattice sites.
So basically, on the positions
where you would see atoms
normally, they can also occur
between lattice sites.
So they're localized rifts,
you can say, in the
periodicity of a crystalline
material.
And here's just an illustration
of the way that
these different point
defects play out.
So let's start out by
looking at this one.
This is a substitutional
impurity atom.
So it's an impurity.
So it's a type of chemical
imperfection.
You can imagine that this is,
for example, some kind of FCC
material like copper, for
instance, and suppose that you
have an impurity of some sort
like iron, and it sits there
and it replace one of the
copper atoms. So this is
called a substitutional
impurity.
It substitutes for the regular
atom that would have sat at
that location.
Substitutional impurities.
There's another picture.
There's your substitutional
impurity up there.
We'll get to the other ones
in just a moment.
We already talked about some
substitutional impurities.
So dopants.
If you have boron or phosphorus
or silicon, that
boron or that phosphorus
replaces the silicon that
would have sat at a certain
lattice site.
So the dopants we've studied
so far are types of
substitutional impurities and
we call them good impurities
because they give us desirable
properties.
They are dopants.
They're good impurities.
Then we have alloying
elements.
I am not a very big fan of
sodas, but if you were
somebody else who is a big fan
of sodas, then you might, for
example, drink a lot of sodas
out of aluminum cans.
Those aluminum cans are really
not pure aluminum.
They're alloys.
They're alloys with other metals
to give them the good
properties that they need
in order for the
forming process to occur.
So if you ask yourself,
how do you actually
make aluminum cans?
They're stamped out from sheets
of aluminum, but it's
not just aluminum by itself.
Aluminum by itself would just
tear if you do that.
So if you alloy it,
you give it better
properties so it's ductile.
You can deform it to very large
strains and that's a
good thing in the case
of alloying elements.
Another one that he showed
you was nickel and gold.
That's if you want to change the
color of gold, if you want
to be very creative when
you're proposing.
So that's a good kind of
substitutional impurity.
There are also contaminants.
Contaminants are bad kinds of
impurities, but before we get
to the contaminants, let me
just show you what good
impurities can do.
So this is the Hope Diamond.
It's in the American
gem collection.
You can actually find
out more about it.
I'm not a big gem expert, but
anybody who looks at this Hope
Diamond can immediately
see that it's a
really pretty diamond.
But you guys are ahead of
everybody, because in addition
to knowing that it's a pretty
diamond, the fact that it has
boron impurities in it already
tells you what the majority
charge carrier is.
So when you go to this gem
collection, you can educate
everybody else.
So those are all good
impurities.
There are also bad
impurities--
contaminants.
Lithium in sodium chloride
is an example.
So if you were using saline
solution, for instance, in an
IV and you had lithium in
there, that is very
detrimental to the person
who's receiving that.
That's definitely
a contaminant.
You don't want those.
That could make you die.
So let's move on to some other
types of point defects.
Here's another type
of point defect.
So just now we talked about the
substitutional impurity atom.
Now we're going to talk about
the interstitial.
The interstitial's very
different from the
substitutional.
In the case of the
substitutional, we have a
lattice site, which instead of
being occupied by the regular
atom that would have occupied
it in a perfect crystal, is
occupied by a chemically
distinct atom.
In the case of an interstitial
impurity, that impurity can
sit in the space in between
lattice sites, so-called
interstitial sites.
That's why we call them
interstitial impurities.
And interstitial impurities or
interstitial atoms can be both
chemical impurities, and
obviously, they are rifts in
the atomic arrangement so
they are structural
impurities as well.
Why do I say chemical?
The reason is because if this
is, for example, iron, if this
is an iron matrix and you have
a carbon atom sitting in the
interstitial site which makes
steel, then that's an example
of a structural defect, but it's
also a chemical defect.
If, for example, you have, on
the other hand, iron sitting
in a nuclear reactor and it's
getting bombarded all the time
by energetic neutrons, then
interstitials are being
created by atoms getting knocked
out of their lattice
sites and they're getting put
into interstitial sites.
So that's creating defects that
are chemically the same
as the surrounding matrix
material, but which are
structurally distinct.
So those are interstitial
atoms.
So here's another picture
of interstitial
atoms. There it is.
It's not sitting on a regular
lattice site.
It's sitting in between
lattice sites.
It's sitting in the space, in
the interstitial space between
atoms. And I already mentioned
to you the fact that if you
put carbon into iron, those
atoms go into interstitial
sites and there would give iron
some of its beneficial
properties, which we
look for in steel.
So some of the good mechanical
properties.
Here's another example of a
situation where an atom goes
into a lattice and create an
interstitial impurity.
So lanthanum-nickel
5 is a prototype
hydrogen storage material.
It takes up a huge amount
of hydrogen.
It takes up a greater density
of hydrogen than liquid
hydrogen, actually, so if you
expose this to hydrogen, the
hydrogen just goes right
in, and it sits in the
lanthanum-nickel 5 lattice
as an interstitial atom.
So this is considered
to be as a prototype
hydrogen storage material.
Unfortunately, it's extremely
expensive so it's not being
used very much these days, but
on the other hand, it goes
well with our gem theme in this
particular lecture in
terms of expensive things.
Here's another example of an
interstitial impurity.
This one is not an
alloying element.
It's a contaminant.
So hydrogen, but this
time in iron.
So hydrogen in lanthanum-nickel
5 is good.
We want to store it.
Hydrogen in iron is bad because
it actually degrades
the mechanical properties of the
iron, unlike carbon, which
gives us steel, which is good.
You put hydrogen in,
it embrittles it.
So hydrogen embrittlement in
steels is a big problem.
And it's actually one
of the challenges
to a hydrogen economy.
If you have steel pipelines or
valves or various pieces of
machinery, structural components
that are made out
of iron that are constantly
exposed to hydrogen, over
time, they're going
to brittle.
They're going to become
very difficult to use.
It's one of the challenges in
that whole undertaking.
OK.
So we're going fairly at a
clip here through these
taxonomy of point defects.
So in the taxonomy of point
defects, perhaps the easiest
defect to understand
is the vacancy.
So when you think of the
vacancy, think of the hole
that we talked about in the
case of semiconductors.
Vacancy is nothing.
It's a missing atom.
So if you have a crystalline
lattice and it's FCC or it's
BCC or it's simple cubic,
whatever you like, and you
know that there's supposed to
be an atom at a certain
lattice site and it's not
there, that's a vacancy.
That's a situation where you
have an unoccupied lattice
site and there are different
ways to form these vacancies.
They can be formed during
crystallization.
If you heat up a material, the
number of vacancies decreases.
So if you quench it really
quickly, you can actually trap
the vacancies before they can
leave in service under extreme
conditions.
I mentioned just a moment ago
that interstitials can be
created if you irradiate a
material, if you bombard it
with energetic particles, like
neutrons for instance, you'll
create interstitials, sure, by
knocking atoms out of their
atomic sites, but what's
left behind after you
knock that atom out?
Vacancies.
So actually, you create two
defects at the same time:
vacancies and interstitials.
So I think we probably have a
picture here of a vacancy.
A vacancy is nothing.
It's just empty space.
That's a vacancy.
There you go again.
Nothing.
So we've gone through a bunch
of taxonomy, right?
So we know now that there are a
number of different kinds of
point defects in crystals.
We've talked about
interstitials.
We talked about vacancies.
We've talked about
substitutionals.
What can we say about these
defects quantitatively?
So let's take the vacancy and
derive or write down what is
the number of vacancies that
you can expect to find in a
given material at a certain
temperatures?
So to do that, let's be a little
bit more quantitative.
Suppose that you
have a crystal.
I'm showing you a plane, for
example, a 1 1 1 plane in an
FCC material and how do
you create a vacancy?
You simply remove an atom.
So you had an atom.
Now you have no atom.
You've created a vacancy.
When you created that vacancy,
you broke all the bonds
between the atom that used to
be there and the neighboring
atoms. Breaking bonds
costs energy.
So it costs energy to
create a vacancy.
It costs energy to remove an
atom from the place where it
would have been because
you're breaking bonds.
So in this case, I have six
bonds that I broke.
If I were looking at some
material, for example, placing
our cubic material in 3D, I
would find that I would be
breaking 12 bonds to the 12
nearest neighbors, and so on
for all the different
crystal structures.
So we actually then take that
information, the fact that
we're breaking bonds, and
encapsulate it in a single
descriptions of how
much energy it
costs to create a vacancy.
And we call that the vacancy
formation energy.
So this is an energy and so
it's expressed in eV.
Its units are electron volts.
You can convert them to joules,
anything you like.
And if you wanted to then
compute how many vacancies
there are in a given crystal,
well, first of all, it costs
energy to make them, so why
would you ever even have a
vacancy in the material?
Well, no material is perfect.
We know that from studying
materials, but what causes it
is the fact that at finite
temperature because of the
Boltzmann distribution that Dr.
Sadoway told you about a
few lectures ago, just like in
the case of intrinsic charge
carrier promotion in
semiconductors, you can get
thermal formation
of vacancies.
So that Maxwell Boltzmann
distribution can actually
cause there to be vacancies
despite the
fact that there are--
that it costs energy
to do that.
So how can we actually use
that to express how many
vacancies we have in
a given material?
So I'm going to write down an
expression for how many
vacancies you can expect to find
at a given temperature on
the basis of their formation
energy, OK?
So let's do that.
This is going to be the fraction
of vacant sites.
So if you have a given
material--
FCC, BCC, whatever you like--
you know that there's a
certain number of lattice sites
per unit volume, and you
learn how to calculate
those things.
And to quantify the number
of vacancies, you have to
basically say, what fraction
of those sites does not
contain an atom?
Is that 1/100 of a percent
or is it 1% or how many?
So this is actually going to be
expressed as a ratio, which
I'm going to call this.
This is the number of vacancies
per unit volume and
this is the number of atomic
sites, also per
unit volume, OK.
So this is the definition of the
fraction of vacant sites.
And how do we express it?
Well, we express it using
a very simple formula.
This formula contains a factor
here which is experimentally
determined.
This is an empirical factor
and then an exponential.
So the exponent we take here,
the vacancy formation energy,
and we divide it by the thermal
energy at the given
temperature of interest.
So this is actually telling you
that to form vacancies,
you actually have two
competing factors.
On the one hand, you have the
bonding energy that makes the
difficult-to-form vacancies
because you're breaking bonds,
you're taking it an atom out.
On the other hand, you have this
thermal energy, Boltzmann
constant times the temperature,
and the thermal
energy is competing with
that bonding energy.
And when that thermal energy
is high enough, you can
actually start knocking atoms
out despite the fact that it
costs you some energy, and
obviously when this ratio is
very large, that means that the
bonding predominates, and
when it gets smaller, that means
the thermal energy is
more and more sufficient to
actually knock atoms out of
their positions and cause
there to be vacancies.
So when you do these
calculations, make sure to use
the absolute temperature in
Kelvin, and dimensional
analysis will tell you the
units of the Boltzmann
constant have to be energy
units per degrees.
So eV's per Kelvin,
for instance.
So this is the absolute
temperature.
This is the vacancy formation
energy and this is the
Boltzmann constant.
So what that means is that at
any given temperature, you'll
actually expect to see some
fraction of vacancies.
So let's actually try to do a
calculation with an actual
vacancy formation energy and see
how many vacancies we get
at a given temperature.
So to do that, we've been
provided with what is the
common currency in science,
which is published
experimental data, which we find
from published journals
which we find online through,
for example, Web of Science.
And from this journal, we find
that for copper, the vacancy
formation energy is 1.03
electron volts.
Furthermore, in the same journal
in the abstract there,
you'll find the magnitude of
this constant A, which as I
told you is experimentally
determined.
This quantity A we call
the entropy factor.
And even though there's no way
to very easily derive it--
I can't tell you what's the
entropy factor for iron and
you can't really tell me just
by thinking about it--
nevertheless, it turns out that
this factor usually fall
within a certain range.
It's usually between
0.1 and 10.
That's usually the range
and what you find As.
And in the case of copper, it's
very much in that range.
It's just 1.1.
So let's use this information
to actually figure out how
many vacancies we expect to
see in copper at the given
temperature.
OK.
So here's my fraction of
vacancies and we know that it
is going to be expressed as 1.1
times exponent minus the
formation energy, which is 1.03
eV, and then we'll put in
Boltzmann's constant, and then
let's pick a temperature.
For the moment, let's just
take room temperature.
So T, room temperature,
and room
temperature's about 300 K.
So when we put in all these
numbers, it's just a matter of
calculating.
This is on your sheet
of constants.
This is the temperature which we
choose at room temperature.
Let's actually write down T,
room temperature, is about 300
K, and we find a certain
number of vacancies.
And the number of vacancies that
we find is 2.19 times 10
to the minus 18 vacancies.
So this is the fraction
of vacant sites.
Well, is that a lot?
Is that a little?
How can we determine whether
this is a lot or a little?
We compare it to the number of
atoms that there actually are,
and in the case of solid
materials, we expect there to
be something on the order--
this has to be compared to
something on the order of
Avogadro's number, but we can
actually calculate more
explicitly that this turns out
to be something like 10
to the 5th vacancies
per centimeter cubed.
And if in a real material, a
solid material like silicon,
for instance, or boron or
whatever you're interested in,
your number of atoms is
something like 10 to the 23rd,
Avogadro's number, right,
then this is
actually a very tiny number.
Compare 10 to the 5th
to 10 to the 23rd.
The number of atoms that are
missing at room temperature is
very low in copper.
We can compute that using
this expression.
However, even though it's
low, it's not zero.
And if we continue going down
in temperature, we'll find
that the number is lower and
lower and lower, but it never
really goes to zero because we
have this expression which
gives us the total number.
So let's do another one and
this time, let's take a
different temperature.
Let's take the melting
temperature of copper.
The melting temperature of
copper is considerably higher.
It's about 1085 degrees Celsius
and we can go through
exactly the same calculation.
1.1 times all these quantities
here times melting
temperature, OK?
And when we do this, we get a
vacant site fraction which is
1.67 times 10 to the minus 4 and
that corresponds to 1.41
times 10 to the 19th vacancies
per centimeter cubed.
So what do we know by--
what can we see now by
comparing these two
quantities?
Number of vacancies, add room
temperature, number of
vacancies at melting
temperature.
How many orders of magnitude
do they differ by?
Huge difference in the number
of vacancies that we find at
two different temperatures.
And why do we see such
a huge difference?
Let's actually write down
what that difference is.
Let's write down the ratio.
The fraction of vacant sites at
melting temperature divided
by fraction of vacant sites at
room temperature is something
like 7.6 times 10 to the 13th.
That's the difference in number
of vacancies you get
just by increasing the
temperature from room
temperature to melting
temperature.
Why is that?
Well, one way to look at that
is just from the expression
that we have to calculate
the number.
Here's where the temperatures
go.
So any difference in temperature
if it's a factor
of two or if it's a factor of
three or if it's a factor of
four, it's going to go
into the exponential.
So that exponential is actually
making a huge
difference as a function of
temperature in terms of number
of defects that you get.
The higher you go up
in temperature,
you don't get just--
you go up a factor of four in
temperature, you don't just
get a factor of four increase
in the number of defects.
You get that in the
exponential.
So the factor of four is
hugely magnified by the
exponential.
So that means that at any given
temperature, even the
lowest temperatures, you expect
to see some defects,
but if you increase the
temperature, you see a hugely
larger number of defects.
And you can use this
sort of expression
for any kind of defect.
So I talked about vacancies
right now and vacancies have a
specific formation energy, but
interstitials also have
formation energies,
substitutionals also have
formation energies.
So you can use this expression
to determine the fraction of
defects per lattice site for any
kind of defect so long as
you have the formation energy
of that defect.
So just to show you how
difficult it is actually to
remove defects, if you have a
crystalline material, defects
want to stay even at the
lowest temperatures.
I have this interesting little
piece of art to show you.
This particular piece of art
was actually discovered, I
guess, by some scientist at
the University of Toronto
where Dr. Sadoway went to
school, and this particular--
what do they call it?
They call it The Atomix.
Let me write down the name of it
in case you want to look it
up because I think they sold a
lot more of these to material
scientists than they sold
to anybody else.
And all this is two plastic
plates, two PMMA plates,
polymethyl methacrylates,
or plexiglass.
And in between them, there's a
little hole that's cut, a gap,
and in that gap are a number
of ball bearings.
And the ball bearings are kind
of like atom, right, so they
move around.
And here we're going to the
document camera right now.
So if you shake these things
around and the ball bearings
are moving around, that's like
introducing temperature.
That's like taking a crystal,
melting it, all the atoms are
bouncing around.
You will even see some vapor
atoms when these sort of leave
the surface and fly through the
air, but then if you stop,
that's like quenching.
That's like suddenly I've taken
this crystal, which was
originally molten, and I've
dropped the temperature.
Here's what I see.
So can you see that?
How to use this thing--
there we go.
So you can actually see a lot
of the defects that we were
talking about just
a moment ago.
Here you can see areas of
perfect crystalline order.
Here's another area of perfect
crystalline order.
So you have many, many crystals
that are adjacent to
each other.
They're oriented differently.
So they're forming
misorientation defects between
themselves.
So for example, here's
a grain boundary.
This is a crystalline grain.
And inside this crystal,
you see a vacancy.
It's right there, So
here's another
instance of the vacancy.
There's another vacancy.
And what happens if I try to
remove some of the disorder?
By the way, interesting thing
is that some of the vapor is
also left here.
So there's the vapor.
If I then try to remove some of
these defects, I can just
tap on this.
If I just continue to tap on
it, I'm removing defects.
The whole thing is crystallizing
more and more
and more so now I put
it down again.
OK.
You still see the vapor phase.
Now you see a big huge crystal
right here with some grain
boundaries around it.
Here's another big
huge crystal.
Here's another crystal.
There's a smaller crystal.
Each one of them is bounded by
grain boundaries, but what do
you see in each of
these crystals?
There's a vacancy.
And you can actually
sit here--
well, not here.
Maybe later, but if you want to
take a look at one of these
things, you can probably go to
Dr. Sadoway's office and pick
it up and he'll let you play
with it for a little while.
You can try to get all
these vacancies out.
the defects out.
No matter how hard you try, if
you spent hours, you'll get
things to be more and more and
more perfect by tapping on it,
but there's always going
to be a vacancy.
Always.
And even if you are extremely
patient, you get things down
to just one vacancy and you
think that all you have to do
now is just give it a little
bit more of a tap to remove
that one vacancy, well, more
often than not, you'll find
that with that tap you'll remove
the vacancy, but create
another vacancy somewhere
else.
So you'll always find
these vacancies in
these crystalline materials.
It's just a consequence of
the fact that when you're
agitating a material like you're
doing here-- you're
shaking it--
that's the same thing that
happens if you have some
finite temperatures, some
non-zero temperature in the
material, you're always going
to be creating some defect.
So that's exactly what this
expression is giving you.
It's telling you that there's
going to be defects at any
temperature, but their number
goes up dramatically as you
increase the temperature.
So let's go back to the
slides real quick now.
OK.
So everything I've told you so
far is concerned with defects
in crystals that are of one
type, so that are made up of a
single element.
But in the case of, for example,
things like ionic
crystals, and ionic crystals
are made up of multiple
elements with multiple charge
states, you can get new kinds
of point defects that
you can't see in a
single element material.
So we'll talk a little bit about
those and when it comes
to those defects in ionic
materials, we have to expand
the taxonomy a little bit.
The taxonomy is now going to
include defects called
Schottky imperfections, Frenkel
imperfections, and F-centers.
So let's go to a visualization
of what these are.
Here you see an ionic crystal.
So you have alternating types
of atoms. You have these big
ones, which are presumably the
negatively charge ones, and
then you have the small
positively charged ones, and
here you have an example of
a Schottky imperfection.
So a Schottky imperfection, it's
kind of like a vacancy.
It's missing atoms. The main
difference between a Schottky
imperfection and a vacancy by
itself is the fact that in a
material that involves
charged atoms--
ions, right--
in an ionic crystal, when you
take atoms out, you have to
make sure to maintain
charge neutrality.
So these materials are
charge neutral.
They have equal numbers of
positive and negative ions,
but you want to make sure
that you take these
out in equal numbers.
So in the Schottky defect, you
take out one negative and one
positive ion, or basically one
unit, one stoichiometric unit.
If you add zirconium oxide,
which is ZrO2, you would have
to take out three atoms to
maintain charge neutrality.
That would be the
Schottky defect.
So here is another example,
another visualization of a
Schottky defect.
So when you take these two atoms
out, nothing says that
they have to be taken out from
right next to each other.
You can take out one here.
You can take out one there.
It's good both ways because in
the end, it's just about
charge neutrality.
It's about maintaining a charge
neutral material.
So we can actually write down
reactions to describe the
formation of these
Schottky defects.
So let's do that.
When we write down reactions to
describe the formation of
Schottky defects, we first
recognize the fact that we're
dealing with empty sites.
We're dealing with void.
We want to see how this void,
or in scientific parlance,
null, is decomposed into two
vacant sites in the particular
ionic crystal that we're
dealing with.
So let's-- to make
things specific,
deal with sodium chloride.
So sodium chloride, we
have two type of
atoms. Sodium and chloride.
And to maintain charge
neutrality, we have to remove
one of each.
So this is actually-- this null
space is actually going
to be composed of two vacancies:
a vacant site on a
sodium lattice where a sodium
atom would have been sitting
and a vacant site
where a chlorine
would have been sitting.
And because this entire process
takes place in the
presence of materials that
are composed of ions--
so ionic solids--
these two vacancies, in fact,
have some charge them.
So when we think about the
charge of these vacancies,
what we actually have to think
of, it's a little bit
counterintuitive.
The sodium in a sodium chloride
crystal is charge
positive, but what does
that make the vacancy?
So if you have a lattice of
atoms that are charge positive
like the sodium atoms and you
remove one of them, what is
the effective charge
of that vacancy?
You have nothing, as Dr.
Sadoway would say,
in the land of plus.
So the charge of this vacancy,
the effective charge of this
vacancy, is going
to be negative.
And we mark that with this
little thing right there.
So void or nothing in land
of plus is negative.
We mark that with one of
these apostrophes.
So what about this vacancy?
That vacancy is created on a
lattice of sites which are
usually charge negative.
So if you have these chlorine
atoms that are charged
negative and you remove one of
them, now you have void in a
land of plus.
So this is going to be
effectively charge positive
and so we have this void
in land of minus.
It is positive.
And we do it--
we annotate it with
one of these dots.
We can do the same thing for
other kinds of crystals.
So I mentioned that in this
case, a Schottky defect would
just be composed of these two
atoms, because these two atoms
constitute the structural
unit for this crystal.
But if we had some other, more
complicated crystal, like, for
examples, zirconium oxide, then
we would still write down
a similar reaction.
So we could put a Schottky
defect into zirconium oxide.
OK.
And so now we have to
figure out how this
reaction plays out.
We have to create vacancies.
Here's our vacancy
on the zirconium.
And because the structural unit
contains two oxygens, we
have to create two
oxygen vacancies.
And now we have to think about
how do we maintain charge
neutralities?
What is the effective charge
on all of these atoms?
So the zirconium sites are
usually the positively charged
atoms, so when we remove one
of them, that's removing
something, that's putting
void basically
into the land of plus.
So we have now a negatively
charged vacancy, and this
negatively charged vacancy has
four negative charges, an
effective minus 4
negative charge.
And the oxygens are the
negatively charged ions, and
so when we create voids there,
these two vacancies have an
effective positive charge, and
because the charges have to
balance, we know that this has
to be effectively two negative
charges and there are
two vacancies.
So we have charge neutrality.
So that's how the Schottky
defects work.
OK.
So let's move on to
Frenkel defects.
In the case of Frenkel defects,
it's really not so
different from Schottky defects
in some sense, except
now instead of dealing with a
situation where we maintain
charge neutrality by removing
two atoms, we actually
displace one atom from its
initial location to a
different part of the crystal.
So we're creating actually a
vacancy right there, and this
atom, which was originally
sitting on a lattice site, is
now displaced to an interstitial
location.
So that's an interstitial.
So a Frenkel defect is a vacancy
and an interstitial.
And here's another view
of a Frenkel defect.
Here, I've removed an atom from
one of the lattice sites
and moved it over to here.
So that's my Frenkel defect.
And in the case of Frenkel
defects I can also write down
reactions for Frenkel defects.
Let's do that.
OK.
So Frenkel defects usually occur
in crystals with widely
differing atomic radii, and in
ionic crystals, the radius of
whatever is positively charged
would have to be much, much
less than whatever the radius
of whatever's negatively
charged occasionally, or very
rarely, but I suppose it's
still possible, you would have
to have basically a very big
difference in radius between
these two cases.
An example of one of these
situations is, for example,
silver bromide, where here the
silver's positively charged
and the bromide ion is
negatively charged.
And we can write down a reaction
to describe the
Frenkel defect formation just
like we did in the case of the
Schottky defect formation.
So in the case of a Frenkel
defect formation, how do we
actually go about this?
We have, for example, can start
out with a silver atom
site and we're going to displace
that silver atom away
from its original site so it
now sits in an interstitial
position and we're going to
leave behind a vacancy.
So let's do that.
OK.
So we're going to have silver
interstitial site and let's
just be clear--
say that this is on a
regular silver site.
And then we have a vacancy left
over on the silver site
and this is the reaction
for the formation
of our Frenkel defect.
Frenkel defects, just like
Schottky defects, preserve
charge neutrality.
So how do we actually
mark down charge
neutrality in this case?
Well, there's no change in
charges in the original state
so we'll just mark
that with an X.
And the vacancy is sitting in
a place that used to be
positive so it's a hole in the
land of positive so we know
that this one's going
to be negative.
And this silver ion, which was
displaced from its original
lattice site, is now going to be
sitting in an interstitial
site which was originally
a land of zero.
So this one's going to
be charged positive.
And now we've balanced, once
again, this reaction.
We have charge neutrality.
We've created a defect and this
is defect, just like in
the case of vacancies, costs
us energy to make.
So we can actually write
down a formation
energy for Frenkel defects.
And this formation energy is
usually a little bit higher
than the formation energy of
vacancies so it's going to be
something more perhaps
on the order of 2 eV.
OK.
So we have gone through--
before I go to this one, let
me just mention one last
defect that you might run into
if you're working in ionically
bonded materials.
An F-center is a situation where
you have a vacancy with
a bound electron inside of it.
And F-centers have the property
that they give
ceramics a tint, a hue.
They actually scatter light
in the visible range
so you can see them.
So with a very short amount of
time left, I wanted to tell
you about a couple of the other
defects that you will
encounter in crystals and one
of the most interesting ones
to me is the dislocation and
dislocations are line defects.
They're 1D defects.
So if you look in, for example,
a corn ear right
here, you can see dislocations
as the termination of a single
atomic plane.
So here's a picture of
what a dislocation
looks like in a crystal.
You have these atomic planes
and here you have
one that just ends.
That's a dislocation.
Some of you probably have
dislocations in your
fingerprints.
So after the class is over, you
can look for dislocations
in your fingerprints.
They're line defects.
So here's another
example of that.
You see that there's an
extraatomic plane which ends.
That's a dislocation.
We mark it with one
of these Ts.
Here's a picture of
a dislocation.
Dislocations actually help
materials to deform easily
without having to shear off.
Here's a little picture of
mine which I really like.
This is the only way that people
really had to study
dislocations before
computers existed.
So now we can study, for
example, dislocation by
simulating them in
real crystals.
And this is a mid-20th
century computer.
It's a raft of bubbles.
It's just a bunch of bubbles
that somebody blew on the
surface, soap bubbles, and
you can deform them.
You can deform this raft of
bubbles by shearing it and
here you see--
what's wrong?
Why isn't it going?
There it is.
There's your dislocation running
through and you see
lots of dislocations running
through this crystal.
This was, by the way, done by
Lawrence Bragg, who you heard
about in connection with
x-ray scattering.
You'll hear about Bragg again
when we get to DNA.
So keep him in mind.